And no way is you can say you remember
. Roger butler and i was obvious to china
from john saw him on the doors point.
And this newspaper photographer
timeline took our photograph
horrify the next day to save
a fight. But this was very early in
the piece i think it was right at the
sun. I mean the contract right at the end
of those point do you remember any of the
other to remember the public works for
toggle for a very well very well he was
a friend of mine and when
he was commissioned to
prepare their stock photographic documentary
evidence of the building at the bridge
. It just for him to walk all over the job
of going to different places here and
there when i had the job of going with him
because of the job needed and so was he
the bob that's right. Band members
assistant brindle which is
a bill brindle. He left during the during
the building of the bridge and went to
work for the newspapers. I have probably
better him but i also got to know after
they are left he got he had an assistant
who took over and i used to go with him he
could have been starting
a flood or something like that. No
hard it can't be sure. You know
we did you ever there was
a photograph taken of the placing of the
last stone in the pylon on the bridge
. And there's a photographer there and
his photographer is out on the end of
a good or
a piece of. And he's taking the photo this
photograph of this and i. There was one
copy of the photograph of the photographer
taking the photograph which i have i was
wondering who he was because he's right
in the middle. You know over space. Well
this is how he used to do this sort of thing
is to go the most amazing places. And
if i if i make
a guess i'd say it would be bound because
he'd be about the only bloke i know i do
think to you. Particular remember
robert byrd and yes he. Well i was
asked to go with him when he was taking
photographs showing all around and if you'd
ever question first who he was there was
somebody there to vouch for him but i
recall that. I want to kasian that he wanted
to take some pictures of the building
of the southern approach where and he
decided to go up on top chimney at the
royal the mining these in there and i found
his way up and took pictures from the
top of it which is about as
a long way to go. And you never went up
there with nothing to do after the fact
that the one you were was did you see any
other photographers wandering around did
you ever see only mallard no i don't recall
seeing any of. I think bradfield had
arranged with him to take
a photograph movie photograph for the
institution of engineers. Well i wouldn't be
where i would know it at
all. Put there was somebody
recollection now who is either associated
with the north sydney north shore
grammar school and he used to take
pictures from the grammar school of the
progress of the bridge and don't want to
kasian he distinguished himself by taking
photographs during a fog sydney
harbour when the bridge was
a merging from the fog lie and you could
see the you could see the two creeper
crimes in the top sections of each
side of the arch. But i remember
a photograph like that taken by frank
cash the. That's the name of the chap you
spoke. He was the clergyman at
a christchurch and i said that's
right. Well after that reminds me
but couldn't recall is nine. Do you ever
meet him. Frank cash. No not that i can to
go. Do you. You did quite
a lot of work other than for the bridge
for bradfield didn't you. Yes but not
during office hours. But this was done
mostly in the evening when i had an
office or a room with jason
to his office and by
a mutual understanding because
he explained before things
the idea settle down into. And to
establish that he couldn't
pay me. So perhaps
in some ways reagan. He can give
something back or in some return.
We want to go to dinner and much
more hotel but which is close handy.
And many and many occasions.
We would go up there.
Haven't we all. And then their return
to the office and perhaps leave leave
the public works department say about half
past eight or nine o'clock at night and
matter fact you see that picture up here.
For some reason rather he gave me that it
was richer by colder. One
of the of the arches
a desire not got the person design.
I think was had been painted by
. I think it was possibly one of the staff
i'm not sure where i can't recall his
name now. But that somehow
or other. Is it's
a cult original in that. No it's
not original is a photograph
a color photograph. Which
that's right. Called
a color that. But that would
probably get that about
you know i can't 1930 see that it is
that he said but he didn't confine his
interests to near south wales. He
was also interested in queensland
. The story bridge. And he is
a state he was quite interested
only in the turning back the rivers
in queensland to fly west for now regained
the western plains of new south wales.
And south of us south us to queensland.
Did you work on any of the any of the
drawings for him for that very likely
probably will probably be baps or some sort
of. And that would be
a 1933 to it. Well it would have been before
and you thirty to it it right because
i just had together my nerves and. And
what about the story bridge did you
complete help him with
a preliminary drawings on that. Yes. There
is some designs that would many designs
actually prepared but it was based on the
actual environment there and whether. I
can't recall whether the final
design was very much like
the earlier designs which we looked at and
then. And what would he. What would he
do he say i want something like this. Will
you work work out what how did he get it
. He can give you the general idea what he
what he's thinking and then hand it over
here and you see what you come up with i
remember all that would different ideas
and different methods of approach
on both sides which involve the
topography of the place but the
same thing happened to all the.
The railway which is designed. Into the
northern suburbs of the coastal areas
here. There were many poor taken
across middle harbour. At the spit
bridge and preparation to
building a bridge across
a little harbour. From sea fourth of
beautiful and somewhere over there. Did you
control the positioning of
those poor boys. Well up to
a point you probably suggest someone get
his agreement. And you go and do some
surveying on it. Well only
mostly yes i did so i did level
a level all the way from the oval to
manly and back but. But the plans were
the route plans were trying to start
or drawing on the plans of the area
official when. Did he give you anything to
do regarding you know i understand that
when the wearing a railway was dropped as
a project. He also proposed
a worrying highway and i notice that this
paper's in the national library of her in
her mongst his papers. Re wearing
a roadway. Did you have to use do with it
though i'm less along you're speaking oh
. Matter fact they even got so far as to
build some of it you know because the
takeoff wish to avoid. All the northern
side of mawson is station from the existing
tunnels and they turned away again
north side turned away to the right.
Underground under the hill and
surfaced somewhere up near
a neutral base of what i can recall the
two years ago for much. Now i see that
no sydney uses them for no sydney university
use them for tagging bats too for
tagging bats. Do they know i don't know
that last i heard they were going much yes
but i was talking later on when the railway
was dropped the proposal was hit one of
his proposals was for
a roadway to wording. Now i don't doubt.
I don't recall anything else that.
What about the low level bridge the design
of that did you see that over how did
you have anything to do with it. Where
over middle harbour no bridges that i can
recall high level bridges. With. I think
the orion or i was at the lower
half of the bridge and the
roadway was above on the top right on
the top. Is only actually seen one
one was on
a slide which was done of dr bradfield slide
which the department of main roads had
which are now in the state archives.
It's a design for a bridge it's
a fairly well it was to design is
actually one is a high level and one was
a low level. No i don't remember anything
of the lower level of intelligence could
have been done is the idea was that it would
be chill awful lot cheaper to make it
a bit lower. You know and the query was
that what large shipping would need to go
in middle harbour anyway. No you'd think
so there's not much out there now. Other
ferries. Do you remember any other extraneous
work that you did for the documentary
you know whenever.
During the building of the bridge. Did you
ever go over the bridge looking at the
work going on there is anything you remember
particularly. I had over many. But if
you're in
a hurry to get to know certainly prefer
to walk over the bridge. Rather than wait
for the ferry and get across that i did you
walk over the arch at all. Oh yes many
times i even went up on well it was just
you know all the answers met. I remember
going to climbing up onto the end of the
creek. You know and taking photographs day
out of the water and it was a whale of
a thousand to show the whale so under
the bridge. He still got their
photograph. Oh possibly i've got
photograph here i haven't looked. Prius it
could probably answer that is probably yes
it's you. The second person that's wrong
about that while there
i met on one occasion
a launch of stannard was taken out by
some photographers chasing it around the
place and it came up under the under the
launcher. Now i don't know i think about
it all this is one of the
fellows who was working as
a holder up on the arts. He told
a story. Now i don't know anything about
it but one thing and i don't know whether
it's been mentioned at all but from
trucks and time. People visitors will be
taken or asked to go over the arch one
side to the other. Well when you get up.
It's not much to hang onto you know and
they lose their nerve. And they get to the
stage where they were actually
physically helpless to accommodate by
and take them down to the lower arch put
them down inside the lower arch and then
get back to the back to the.
Down. All of the surface again
by inside the arches themselves. I thought
that they didn't join up all the way
through they did they could actually walk
right through and so much as you could
walk right through. I said you could never
dropped off you could walk through it
but i think i still recall photographs
of gordon stuckey when he was taking his
check measurements with extra i think
they called extend someone xed so much as
measuring the stresses in the in the members
themselves by the difference in length
and i can well remember
seeing photos. I had some as
a matter of fact but they were all with
a national library people there. Yes i seen
the photographs of gordon stuck inside
it was
a one another engineer with him constant
kind of which when it was no i don't know
who it would be i mean you weren't involved
in that at all. No no i was principally
on both approaches in some detail and
helping general to bradfield generally
on you know it alls usual things that i
did when you were you said you were you
were up the top of the creeper crane when
before the arches were joined tell me did
was there an impression of the two halves
swaying around at all. No i never felt
like i don't never up them very windy
weather with that sort of thing i think
and as people reckon they used to sway
slowly sometimes with the changes in
temperature at different. Yes that was. That
was. In all in the actual joy of the two
arches you see they were both unsupported
except right back up there that the
arch fins and get the conditions right.
Did you have you been told about the holes
in. Oh i know you know all about it. So
how they had to select the day when it was
the temperature was uniform the whole
structure was the right temperature
before i can know when so they can make
a drive the way just. And also to
determine to join it from my three
hinged to
a two hinged arch that was the day when
it had to be correct. Wasn't it. Yes yes
that was right the upper section was
put in after the last two halves admit
. Was there any other particular occasion.
Do you remember when are you. If you
have the joining of the arch do you have
it. Were you up there that i wasn't there
i member of the i knew it was happening.
What was going on and i don't purpose and
maybe there were others then plenty
during the opening of the bridge. Oh yes.
We were the right and i have an effect
on my mother and wife and i were there
. I. With bill eyes had the
job of put in the river and
position. There was
a joke about this because it will be several
british reviews. One. I don't exactly
would want to cite one in the
middle and some down the south and
i well i. I brought them home. Here
to someone not here now. It was for the
population of forget where i am and
. Noticed they had been put together by
another wife of one of the other members of
the staff and they had been
very closely say it onto
a couple of sections of pipe. A copper
pipe about half an inch diameter
outside diameter probably the stitching had
been paul very very tightly so that in
the event we realized in the event of any
considerable for the stitching were just
ripped and the rebels would fall off the
two fastenings and. This wasn't discovered
until we got to work to put them out. I
thought gosh what if it blows hard during
the morning and i start
a flapper what'll happen is the stitching
or pull out and then and then the remoras
will come adrift completely. So there's
nothing we could do. It had the timetable
was fixed. You know as far as we were
concerned. So what was done was to put the
remains that we hand in position at
the places there were one or two
spare ribbons which anticipation
of trouble later on. Were down in
the hole and. Down in the tollbooth.
We'd taken the precaution to
have some what did what. What do you mean
dissipation in some trouble later on. Do
you expect trouble. Yes yes it was well
known going to be the chance i
would somebody or other this was
a good deal of the new guard particularly
that was likely to create some difficulty
. So this has been far as we were
concerned we did what we could were i
can explain to you. So
a couple of things that howard.
Eventually yes indeed. But we had
chaps. At the river. Whose job it was
once the agreement had been cut by when
they had. To return with the reverends
that they were looking after there was no
chance of anybody else so they were changing
and they had to bring all. The room in
all the full length
back and we had that as
a troll only well i however that
he got all he hasn't gone. And
. We met
a fact it was me who had the job
of designing the the first link
which was was
a reuse on the southern side of the
bridge just south of the tollgate. To
accomodate their official
yes you know. The
trestle was struggling or sitting it was
just immediately south of the bridge
across there to be used by the premier
and in the opening of the bridge. I'm
getting
a bit wet like browsing.
And i was fortunate in
being able to arrange quite good
seats for the opening my wife and my
mother and i had the three top corner seats
overlooking the overlooking the british
are the river in itself. And with
a strict instruction that if anything
happened in the way of the british the river
and being cut then hambone like and i were
to go down into the tol barad get the
spare room and run it across in place
of the wonders why we now are just.
While this was all going
on and. The guy who was
you know to get to good. Whom
we saw and noticed. Was on
a horse and one of the who was started
and this he and my wife knows
about it more and i when
i do. He started to
disturb his horse here and there's
a horse champing around and we heard somebody
say in the name of something or other
and good the group then with an upward
stroke cut. The room and he was
quickly apprehended by policies of
detectives that were all over the place and
carried he was only
a little ma'am they got him under his arm
to his feet were about six inches off the
ground and they carried him in the across
the roadway down into the tailgates and
then from where behind us. And
or to somewhere were their own
their own come presumably.
But another section.
The electrical people had
also been asked to design
a device. But in the event of
the river and having been cut.
Nothing else would happen because associated
with the cutting of the bridge there
were airplanes were to fly around to be
a procession over there were some pride
on the harbour or sort of it. Flags
to fly under the actual cutting
operators all this once. So the
chap. It was
a row electrician who did the hadley hadley.
That's a do you know whether they had
a minute walk down he was watching the river
and doing and he could only throw the
final switch. I'm just
a moment before the rules cut itself. Well
fortunately the device the precautions
operated quite well. Nothing happened. So
what do you do then you go and get the
other one. No we didn't know me there. So
well somebody else came up and joined it
in the middle of the motive who are they
were i don't know that they were so yes
berryman's weren't used. I got
a bit. I showed you after this. But actually
what happened with the spirit was not
a good deal demand for spare rooms and
a few days later the river
and that were used to
a cut in the links that also included
some of the spares and handed
a most politicians and other other
prominent people who or i found i found
a bit of myself for the other matter fact
i've probably got it out here and. Just
so it probably was
a nut revenues rich right across the whole
region. I don't think i don't think any
of the review that we cut was on the bridge
at the time there. But. They wasn't the
years. Yes there were stirring times what
happened to you then after the bridge.
We were transferred from
my node and then. Oh
i would say within a matter of
a few months i was transferred to work on
the south western division straight to
them for
a number of years. Were you. Designing
bridges down there or what are you doing.
Yes but not quite the same size it
is designing bridges there were
prints of ridding out making standard
drawing fit into the enviro into the design
now than the other way around. Do you
remember who standard drawings those were
standard. They would be just departmental
departmental design department
lead design bridges. Whether they
could they could be called green
timber. Or. Just concrete. I suppose
we some steel registry would
we didn't worry about new steel bridges
and so was division. I just happened to
notice that looking through the department
of main roads standard design of the
period that some were done by bradfield
and some were done by harvey day there.
No. Well they were old ones anyway they
were mainly timber the ones i thought they
would probably be all these old the old
standard public works department bridges
which was the usual thing. Up until
advent of the vital moment you were
there and bradfield went redesigned all
the standard designs at one stage in the
proceedings to upgrade the ones. Well there
wasn't really upgrading what they were
doing is likening the design previous to
that they had they had to use gigantic
heavy timber and what they did was lighten
the design up to use smaller standard
sizes of timber in well that might well
i think but i wouldn't be aware of that
because i wasn't there and. I saw
a standard design of bradfield as
well. Dated nineteen zero two. It was
a small concrete ring all that
was probably was the real use
a lot of they were made out of the money
of pipes. And with walls with we were also
then. And you remained you remained
on the on the department main roads
for many years did you. Oh no no no. Weather
department main road i i i was there
six years but. I had
a lot of things. Personally as wouldn't be
a little bit of interest. Yeah. They were
very tough people who work very very
tough and they were under the
control of rely very largely
a lot of clique you know amongst the
engineers themselves and to be forced
to join the department staff by methods
which i have already tell you about. It
through us and into discard they were
not readily accepted. So all of you.
Engineers that came in from the
railways were not accepted.
I seem to recall that there was
a possibility that some of the staff would
not be accepted by the bottom line or
whether this was ever put into effect. I
don't know but you never sort of prospered
in the department was that it. You know i
don't never possibly know i didn't like
that until many engineers are maintained
and the questions of seniority. And and
even there are there are their
appointment status on appointment was
really in question times. It wasn't
a very happy union it was no happy marriage
put it that way but it worked itself
out largely by the staff who didn't like
the place getting out and you were one of
them. Where did you go. I went i
went to the wrong road transport and
family traffic and also on how
do you go there. I finished up
a traffic engineer but. That was
after belies weld i was there.
Chief there chief traffic engineer and i
followed his eyes but i that's where i
retired. So they're resigned
in 1967. Tell me you remember
bill lush well i take it. What sort
of person was here or delightful
a liar. I got on very
very well with him he was
a personal friend of mine own
ears and by the way that's
a view but have you got in touch and this
is like. No i never never never gotten
hunter because he was already dead. I
didn't. Didn't pursue it. Build i and he is
not in forty eight he had a
bad kidney. This is not had
a band kidney complaint you and
and bell joined the bridge
together. Join the metropol right away.
Construction work on i think it was the
second same nineteen.
Oh i did so were. Somewhere about that
time i just can't remember but. We
were both. Transferred. Immediately
in the metro railway construction
branch and where he was and been employed
as an engineer i was employed last one.
Oh i have it just
a minute now bradfield was responsible for
the metropolitan railway construction
before. It was came under
the railways when the the
. Norton griffith contract was abandoned.
Then the construction of the railways was
transferred to the railways from the public
works we did you come over with them
come out. Where did you come over from the
from the public works to the railways
then i came though it was the right or i
can say action was the first job i had
in narrow ways or if the government at
all and you were with bill nash you both
came in at the same time and
at the same time. And he was
a very nice like we got you
know a very well. Well
a very well and this went
on till the bentley devise.
So you work with him did you go to the
public to the department of main roads as
well. No not. No he was
anticipated going but he was.
Don't like the idea of tall. And he
managed to get an appointment of
she. No i think he was
. I think he was.
No where abouts was it. Never mind if you
can't remember charge of traffic in the
department of railroad transport and
tramways which involved both trams and buses
that time and it was then when
he was in with that money.
Arranged for me while i throw it was
through his his system so help that i got
a job with the same crowd again i came
back i was appointed as assistant engineer
. On the bridge in the early days. Before
the contract had actually been let.
Do you remember the the starting of the
drive driving of the tunnel and the
building or no sydney
station the well they had
a first turning of the side and all that
sort of timber these i remember the
construction the rhetoric borrow way when
they were excavating james station for.